que Cuba no pudo aprovechar 12 hits en
este Duelo
Exacto Saludos Ángela Juan en una poco
común invernal mañana en Florida Pues sí
Juan como bien decías doce hits y
llenaron las bases en el primer inning
sin auto si no pudieron aprovechar
solamente anotaron una carrera Alan
wright el de 41 años pudo recuperarse y
dominar el partido también lo hicieron
sus relevistas a pesar de que como bien
decías pegaron 12 hits nada los bates
cubanos tienen el problema de los
últimos años no producen con personas en
base y esto es una constante desde el
clásico mundial el primer clásico
mundial de 2006 desde que los cubanos
quedaron en segundo lugar con Japón tria
torner bueno está encendido te doy un
dato Juan en 48 horas tría Turner ha
empujado cuatro carreras y ha dado tres
jonrones simplemente es inexplicable ya
que tuvo un inicio de torneo un poco en
silencio según los analistas es un
noveno bate disfrazado que ha despertado
a la ofensiva del equipo estadounidense
recordemos también que Estados Unidos es
un equipo All Star entre algunos premios
que tiene acá te tengo el dato tiene
tres mvp tres novatos del año 18 All
Stars 5 guantes de oro y muchos otros
más Juan Rafael Cómo estuvo el ambiente
de este partido un Cuba contra Estados
Unidos en Miami hubo una pequeña
manifestación en la previa del encuentro
en rechazo al gobierno de Cuba y también
se vieron eslogans en ese sentido en la
grada en el campo incluso hasta hubo
espontáneos que saltaron al terreno de
juego
síjuana era de esperar que en Miami
epicentro de las personas que adversan
al sistema político que en Cuba se vive
se manifestarán en contra al principio
como bien decías unos pocos se
manifestaron o fuera del estadio dentro
del estadio al uníso los corearon muchas
consignas políticas pero el fuerte
estuvo al final donde se tuvo un
lenguaje más fuerte al término del
partido incluso algunos cubanos apoyaban
a los Estados Unidos no estaban de
acuerdo que lo sea representantes de
grandes ligas jugaran por el equipo
oficial cubano pero otros y otros fueron
a disfrutar el partido y como bien dices
algunos se lanzaron al terreno Pero
bueno los temas políticos se deben estar
separados como decían algunos allá del
deporte
pendientes entonces Rafa de la de
segundo final ese que conoceremos
gracias por este reporte desde Miami de
clásico